[music playing]
NARRATOR: In Mossel Bay,
South Africa, Alison Towner
and Enrico Gennari investigate
if speed is what makes
a great white's jaws so deadly.
Other investigators have seen
how a bull shark's bite works.
Now, getting a bite
impression might
help them solve the mystery
of how a great white combines
bite force with thrust.
[splash]
[inaudible]
[music playing]
[water splashing]
[cheering]
Oh, wow!
This shark just came out of
the water, vertical open mouth
almost like saying, look at
me, how majestic animal I am.
This is definitely
the biggest shark
that we've had so far, guys.
He gave a big bite,
and he's still playing
around for a good two minutes.
So we should have got some
very nice bite imprint.
[water splashing]
NARRATOR: They've
got their results.
Get it up, got it.
NARRATOR: And they're revealing.
Wow.
Wow, wow.
It didn't just bite it.
It launched out the water
with it in his mouth.
We couldn't have asked for
better teeth impressions.
Look at this.
This is gold.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: The deepest
bite impressions are most
likely from the initial strike.
[water splashing]
We've got huge amounts
of teeth marks there.
These being the top
teeth of the shark's jaw,
and then on the reverse
side, here we can
see the lower jaw perfectly.
This shark has all of
her teeth in place.
NARRATOR: We can only move
our bottom jaws for eating.
A great white can move
both top and bottom.
But for a shark
capable of decapitating
a seal in one bite,
the damage to the decoy
is surprisingly minimal.
Maybe, they don't
have as much high bite
force as other species,
but be that the speed alone
and the impact of
the force of the hit
is more powerful than
the actual bite force.
So there's lots of
complexity to tease apart.
Coming up.
NARRATOR: White sharks
combine bite force
and thrust to attack their prey.
Their teeth are long, sometimes
close to seven inches.
With that many
daggers, this shark
may not need as much bite
force as a bull shark.
While the bull shark's
teeth act like a buzz saw,
a white shark's function
like a guillotine.
Great white sharks
have 24 teeth on the top
and 26 on the bottom.
You can liken it to a
whole series of steak
knives in a fish's mouth.
The top teeth are the cutters.
They are highly
serrated, and they
are basically the teeth that saw
into the flesh of their prey.
The bottom teeth
are very different.
They're much more narrow
but equally as serrated.
So as the bottom teeth
pin and hold the prey,
the top teeth cut
through the flesh.
And those mechanics
together make the bite
so powerful and so effective.
[music playing]